[Music]
[Music]
all right so folks we got uh adam in the
house we have any in the house we got
tom and dallas okay yes right before
tom was doing his uh stand-up in front
of adam and vinnie killing it and they
were critiquing him i think tom should
do one of those jokes what do you think
and by the way it just
you got to realize i said for the
longest time tom's jokes
require an mba but but these
mother-in-law jokes just require a sense
of humor so
just to kick it off let's test and by
the way score it if you like it
you know give it a thumbs up if you
don't like it just put a score in the
chat box and tell us how you like it tom
start people's day with a smile let's
see what you okay everybody take a deep
breath
man
last week and a half my mother-in-law's
funeral was just horrible the family is
we're still terrible
it was there were tough moments uh the
first part was the way she was waving
her arms
it was so hard to close the casket
we were just um and then later you know
once the banging stops on the inside of
the casket takes about seven minutes
there's no there's no air in there
people that wanted to pray were just
saying man can you just tell the band to
turn it down so it was just kind of a
what a rough week it was a rough day are
you okay are you gonna be all right i i
think i was gonna be fine you know
okay that's tom jokes all right there we
go
what do you say zero to ten i'm gonna
give him an eight like the dedication
the set like i know you're gonna cry
first i thought you were because when he
said i really thought what i do know
vinny you know you're pissed off right
now his wife is pissed off right now
with that joke anyways we got some
stories here to go through before we get
into it let me just kind of give you
some of the stories we gotta
uh pelosi is uh visiting taiwan adam's
extremely concerned maybe you'll give
your sentiments on why you're worried
about that
uh monkey pox 5800 cases i think a
handful of people have passed away new
york in california has already called it
a public health emergency but we'll see
if other states will follow through
as well uh president biden got coveted
for the second time and and trump had a
nice
gesture some nice words to say about it
mansion's got some stuff that's going on
here with the
uh what they're doing raising taxes and
uh
a 75 mile long building is being built
in saudi arabia
110 stories high let me say this one
more time a 75 mile
long building trump would call that a
wall like you know the the trump yeah
the wall can you imagine so they're
building a 75 mile long building that's
futuristic
bathroom i knew you did that yeah it's
not the end of the hall yeah good luck
later
in two weeks so anyway so that's
happening we'll talk about that the fox
news owner rubert murdoch is cooling on
trump reports say amid wider sign of
discontent they're kind of distancing
themselves from trump we'll see what
that story looks like
on navy day putin says united states is
main threat to russia
china's shadow is looming over the u.s
this week with obviously all the stuff
that's going on leader of al qaeda was
uh shot and killed he was killed last
night i believe yes
yesterday
we'll talk about the number two for bin
laden if you can pull up that story
tyler and prepare for it so maybe we'll
go through that tom's got an update for
us with the housing crisis on what's
going on president biden
helped exxon mobil score their biggest
profit
uh on record ever uh which is pretty
impressive to see that taking place will
smith it is uh you know apologizing to
chris maybe
we'll have some thoughts on that amber
heard a selling or eight million dollar
home if you guys are interested to pay
off her debt with johnny depp
and then uh a few other things that's
going on here as well which we'll talk
about prince charles accepted 1.2
million from osama bin laden
family reports claim this is an insider
story
tiger woods is eventually now a
billionaire he would have been one much
sooner but he's finally a billionaire
and uh you know that the zielinski vote
publicity kind of misfired and it
backfired on them but tom why don't we
start off give us an update on what's
going on with real estate i'll read one
of the stories
and then i'll turn it over to you
uh one one thing is facebook and a top
u.s economist fact checked by facebook
for stating the country
in a recession okay so this is a top
economist he says he thinks we're in a
recession
and facebook comes out and says yeah no
it's not really in recession and they
fact check it so let me read this entire
story to you
on thursday the stop economist fell
victim to facebook fact checkers when he
stated that the united states is in the
recession following the release of the
gdp report
which showed negative growth for the
second consecutive quarter this standard
definition of an economic recession we
live in an orwellian healthscape
facebook is now fact-checking anyone who
questions the white house's
ward games about the definition
recession phil magnus wrote on twitter a
researcher and educator with the
american institute for economic research
how wild has it been that an economist
is being fact checked by facebook tom
what do you think about that well i
think right now
we've got
the tech companies what are they scared
to death of they're scared to death of
congressional hearings and so they're
trying to play nice with washington and
i call this a softball from the tech
from thanga right this is just a
softball they're coming out there and
saying oh we're not really in a
recession because the white house said
we're not really in recession and
they're trying to play nice remember
facebook was the odd man out after the
election facebook took the heat and
criticism from the dnc well you
basically let trump and let russia you
were the guy you were the ones that
weren't really watching your front yard
remember all those criticisms of
facebook so i think facebook this is
nothing more than facebook takes a zero
risk thing of creating a headline of
coming back and saying oh yeah yeah no
we kind of agree you know there's uh
there's no recession here and that's
just ridiculous everybody who's looking
at all the statistics that have been
used for 50 years
the technical statistics are out we're
in a recession and by the way just ask
anybody who's at the supermarket what's
going on right i think it's pretty
simple it's this is facebook this is
their they're trying to make vinnie what
do you think about it i just i
i just think people are are just out of
touch and the fact that we let them get
that powerful it's just
it's nuts and it's not going to stop and
then and then november is coming so it's
going to get even i can't wait i can't
let's play devil's advocate let's play
devil's advocate is there anything wrong
with that adam is there anything wrong
with facebook fact checking and
economists saying he thinks we're in
recession right now
so just so we're clear the the economist
was saying that we're in a recession and
facebook the economist was saying we're
in the recession because of two quarters
general gdp being down
and facebook comes out and says no we're
not on a recession you know fact
checking and saying it's not necessarily
the definition i just i don't understand
the moving of the goal post for
i i think i believe it was you that
posted a clip of bill clinton sitting
down i'm glad you said that can you pull
up the bill clinton clip from 2001 yeah
also watch it i don't like the moving of
the goal post if something is a
representation by definition just watch
what it is here's what bill clinton said
it's the economy sitting next to a man
named george so what do you think about
a recession
well a recession is two quarters in a
row of negative growth i don't think
we're going to have that
but we couldn't keep up five percent
growth a year you know forever so
most of the i think 49 of the 50 blue
chip
but i think there'll be things to be
managed he'll have economic challenges
and
you ought to give him a chance to meet
them and not try to figure it all out in
advance does it look like a guy that
just hooked up with look how happy he
looks and look how shitty george bush
looks he was definitely he was hooking
up with monica at this point right
look how happy he looks that's the guy
that's getting late not from hillary but
look at that look at that look at the
grin
this must have been that's the guy that
had two very rough years going into this
21 years yeah this was after he was
impeached but this was unhappy i assume
this was right at the transition from
the to the in 2000 to the jordan
president transition exactly so in
january
that's my guy by the way i mean he's
just look at how happy he's getting
[ __ ] or not i don't really care
he was happy looking like he's a happy
guy
he was smooth man i got to tell you but
anyway get to your initial point he said
it then i will say it again if by
definition a recession is two quarters
of negative gdp growth yeah it is what
it is and i will say that it wasn't
disastrous gdp would have just come back
at uh 0.9 negative 0.9 so it's not
you know it's not crumbling but by
definition we are in a recess yeah but
democrats on the recession side adam but
on the inflation side i think people no
doubt yeah but it's not but that's
inflation is not a recession but that's
just by gdp it just seems like the left
is they're changing the difference
between everything the economy is not
run in reverse at a horrifying rate but
it is it is a recession but is it one of
the worst recessions on record not
yet
but inflation is is rough on the average
person and that's what sucks so i was
having a call yesterday with you know
how they say if you want to find out
what's going you know whether there's a
recession or not you go to what you know
a few different places by the way i love
what manchester said in an interview
with uh
uh what's the guy from fox news the guy
that always has mansion breadth bearer
yeah he said he says look
you know uh 17 uh nobel laureates said
that inflation was transitory you know
and look what happened to them and these
are 17 you know nobel prize
laureates that are talking about this
who still have jobs with linkedin who
still have jobs but they got up and they
said no this is transitory you don't
have to worry about it and this word
transitory yeah listen there's a few
words we learned in the last 12 months
okay one is transitory we learn about
entanglement we learn about there's a
few words that the definitions forever
change and woman and woman doesn't mean
woman you think they can certainly
certainly certain words be just very fun
but kamala harris border doesn't mean
border i could be a thousand miles from
the border yeah we've been to the border
we learned about the word insurrection
and i wasn't familiar with that word
yeah it doesn't even know what that
means
but the point is the point is with the
you were talking about what you were
saying uh a minute ago you're saying uh
uh what point were you making you were
saying there's inflation there is a gdp
growth gdp growth but you were saying
something that prompted me to watch
without agreeing with it with adam it
was that the recession is not like the
worst on record yet but but certainly
inflation is hurting the average person
let's talk about that and before what i
was talking about was facebook that they
were really trying to do a make good
with the us government and now and i
think they're even walking that back
yeah anyways look if if these the way to
judge to see if anything's happening to
the economy
is through
shopping
through 99-cent stores which by the way
these 99-cent stores right now are being
full again there's a story on it which
we'll read about here in a minute this
is going to sound funny but strip clubs
uh you know additional places people go
to you you can ask a lot of interesting
folks
how money is being spent you can talk to
people who are getting tips you can talk
to a lot of our people being a little
bit tighter i talked to one the top uh
baseball card guys yesterday the
baseball card industry had a nationals
this last week and when the nationals
happen
people show up from all over the place
to go to the nationals it's like the nba
all-star game happens once a year they
had it this last week they had some of
the biggest cards
on there one of the cards right now
that's on sale on heritage auctions they
just reached out to me to see if i'm
interested it's going to be it's a
mickey mantle
52 tops sgc 9.5
starting bit was at 5 million they're
estimating this card's gonna go between
nine to fifteen million bucks by the way
heritage auction pat is interested i
don't know is it one of is it one of the
things something i assume you're
interested in yeah i am interested in
this but i don't know if i'm gonna go
that high for that card is this one of
the mantles this is one of the mantles
there's four cards of man there's three
psa tens there's one sgc nine and a half
this is one of them and the guy that's
selling it look one he's selling it look
when he is selling it if he would have
sold it a year ago he would have gone a
few million dollars more than he would
get it right now so he's off in a market
by about a year the card market is down
20 to 50 percent
okay let me say this one more time the
card market is down 20 to 50 percent
which means guys were paying
500 000 for a card last year that card
is going to go for 300 000 this year
okay guys we're spending 32 000 on a
basic psa 10 lebron james card today
it's going for 16 000 12 000
so that's a big difference those are
some of the stuff that you're noticing
but by the way it's still early i mean
if you look at what's going on with the
mortgages we have record-breaking equity
right now okay people are still sitting
on record-breaking equity right the
challenge is with the folks that are
sitting on record-breaking equity
most people are trying to sell their
house for a price that will not sell
today so you may think what is really
equity think about what equity what is
really equity it's like a price on the
stock market that goes by and unless you
do something today it's just the price
that's going by so so you so so so you
know how
unrealized gains dude like that's
exactly right it's like watching a
ticker it's like when a guy owns a few
hundred million dollars
on paper of a company which i know a
couple guys like that when you own a
couple hundred million dollars on paper
yeah and then that's converted to cash
there's a big difference between
because it's just like there's a big
difference between the paper and the
cash right so so a lot of people that
are like well i got four hundred
thousand dollars in equity i got three
hundred thousand dollars in equity i
would probably say the best bet if you
got equity right now
is uh try to refi okay try to refinance
a refund try to re now try not try to
refi try to see if you can get the
obviously don't go
figure right away if you can get a home
equity line of credit and
sit on the sidelines with that if you
can do something because
if you can then it's true equity if you
don't it's just you think you got equity
we're not going to know what are people
willing to pay for that house if a
person was willing to pay million
dollars for it last year is it 9.50
today is it 900 is it 8.50 what's that
number we don't know so i think we're
still gonna figure out the next three
six months what is
going to really happen every month the
one thing about winning and losing okay
when you're winning
you know and you win for a long time you
think you're gonna win forever and
you're not okay the thing about losing
is what what you're losing for a long
time
you think you're gonna lose forever and
you're not
[ __ ] can turn very quickly good and bad
so if you're overly overly optimistic
maybe drink a little parapet or no yeah
you know may not be bad for you to get a
little paranoid and if you've been
losing a little bit too much maybe it's
good you go about re buy the book norman
vincent peel the power of positive
thinking and uh have a drink or two of a
positive thing and see what it does for
you but regardless of what's going on
uh we don't really know exactly what's
gonna happen with the market the next
three to six 12 months we just know the
numbers indicate this is not good bill
gates says success is a lousy teacher
and that every town every now and then
if you have a setback on a product
launch or something it's actually a good
teacher he didn't wish for that and he
was a bit of a tyrant when things didn't
go well but he's absolutely right
success is a lousy teacher but i think
there is an exception to your rule uh
fans of the detroit lions
are not convinced that losing never ends
so we'll just
same thing for the jets but by the way
about a month ago when we when you
really started seeing some of the signs
of this recession it could have been
prior to that
you kind of give a message to the
audience out there like guys pump the
brakes on buying luxury goods louis
vuitton gucci
you know let's stop buying the bags like
you know you give a warning uh
to
our our gentlemen out there you know
tell the wives maybe we won't do this
right
um
you know you put up tyler is there is
this ironic you have this up right now
the crypto collapse has flooded the mar
yeah market with rolex and patek exactly
so i actually had a conversation with a
good a buddy of mine who's like the
watch guy in miami shout out to my boy
jake if you need rolex's like he's the
guy right
uh and i actually text him i was like i
just want to check like he's my boy he's
getting married soon i'm just checking
in with him i said what's the state of
the watch market what do you see because
the guy's made a freaking killing
there's no way you're buying a high-end
watch we'll see about that pbd um but he
i said what's the the stock uh what's
the status of what's right the watch
market
you know is it correlated with what
you're seeing in crypto and real estate
in the stock market which is obviously
taking a big hit
he says quote unquote the watch market
is more of an indication of a correction
first it's the first luxury good to
weaken the first all right i saw this at
the beginning of march and i've adjusted
accordingly it's not someone it's not
something someone needs so it's the
first to go that's right so we're
starting to see it basically what you
recommended
shedding this excess uh luxuries from
your life
to slim down essentially what he's
saying yeah and by the way the the one
of the uh daytona watches one of the
rolexes went up from 35 000
to 240 during the pandemic it's down to
190. still it's from time to time those
numbers again it went from 35 yep to 240
it's down to 190 today still one guy
it's still down it's still one night but
it was 45 from 35 to 240 to
and still won 24 months yeah in 24
months wow this watch was uh
it's it's uh it's it's a it's a
different economy we're going to find
out what's going to happen with people
spending again like the point is
there are so many markers like you know
how what do they say you know if you if
your uh left side of your chest hurts
you start having certain feelings in
your left arm and your left leg what
sign is that might be a stroke okay so
it's a stroke or heart attack okay hey
would you say angina
but the point is the point is like you
know you know how you come home you eat
uh you drink a lot okay if you drink a
lot of alcohol
and you eat a lot of pizza what are you
gonna feel like in the morning when you
wake up [ __ ] come over okay listen
if you add fuel bad energy if you go
drink six cups of coffee except if your
name is mario how should you feel
absolutely that's it yeah
yeah crashing right
the weirdest thing about this economy is
there are so many indicators that are
showing towards what should happen
that we're not gonna know if it's gonna
happen or not this is this is the thing
about this economy today that's very
weird that's got everybody confused
because nobody really knows exactly
what's going to happen even with that
even with you not having a clue what's
going to be happening your job is still
to figure out your own prediction and
preparing for that and persevering
through these bad times no matter what's
going on you have to make your own set
of predictions anyways okay so tom uh
home prices housing anything we need to
know with housing yeah i think but
people if you're trying to sell right
now and you have to sell let's say your
job is moving and you're looking at
potential recession you're looking at
things happening and you're looking like
you got to move right now you i think
you just need to be realistic with what
you do at that house because we're
seeing houses i was just scanning
markets and not just south florida where
we are down here or dallas i was
scanning like phoenix i was scanning
atlanta you know and kind of northern
areas of atlanta where people have and
houses are on the market for a while and
i noticed that people haven't moved the
price down but i'm looking at houses
that look perfectly reasonable you
understand housing but they haven't
moved the price at all and i'm then then
i look at zillow you can flip it over to
recent sales and i'm like man these
people either need to get realistic
about the price or maybe they're under
the loan and the financing underneath
they can't sell at the lower price
otherwise they have to
they'll be underwater they'll be
underwater contribute if you have to go
right now to another market you need to
get out and be realistic of what you can
get out and i hope you're not upside
down on on that but the and the other
thing is just statistically looking at
this
right now we've got a decline in home
sales that's accelerating it was three
percent decline now it's five percent
decline five point four percent decline
i think that the we're seeing the demand
run up a curve right now in other words
the net the change in demand is getting
is accelerating at a rapid rate remember
at the beginning of the year gas went
like 350 national average 363 national
average 375 national average and all the
sudden it went to five remember that big
jump
that's the same thing if you're
listening and you're considering moving
home that's the same thing will happen
housing demand it drops three percent it
drops five percent all of a sudden the
report comes out that it's up 15 percent
so if you got to sell your house you get
a roll right now if you're thinking
about buying a house right now i
wouldn't do it number one your
underlying mortgage is going to be
higher and number two i think you gotta
wait for those um the artificial equity
i call it you know as a result of two
trillion dollars pumped into the economy
has inflated housing prices artificially
and we got to wait for those to settle
back down so if you're looking to buy
right now and you're in even something
close to a reasonable lease hang with
the reasonable lease and look next
summer to buy i want to read something
here from a
moody's chief economist so you know how
moody's they don't have a you know
they're just kind of like giving you
what they think it is and fyi guys
whatever experts are saying right now
take it at face value and do whatever
you want to do with it but you got to
hear both sides here's what he's saying
mark housing correction is dead ahead
warren's moody's chief economist mark
zandy
here's how he sees things playing out
over the next several months this is a
yahoo news story
existing home sales showed a 5.4 decline
in june
from may but prices remain elevated
according to the national association of
realtors the median sale price of
existing homes in the u.s set a new
record high of 416 in june
marking a 13.4 increase from a year ago
yet for those continuing to watch these
rising home prices chief economist
moody's anal analytics mark zandy warns
that a correction could be dead ahead
mortgage rates continue to climb as
interest rates rise further with some
forecasting and short-term rise of
three and a quarter on a 30-year fixed
rate loan mortgage rates are now sitting
at about six percent
as these rates rise mortgage payments
can be several thousand dollars higher
than they were a year ago zandy says and
this loss of affordability exactly why
he sees a correction in the near future
if we stay around six i think that the
market will adjust and we'll eventually
get that correction if it goes much
higher then we'll get a more significant
pullback in the housing market this is
what i'm talking about yeah so you have
a 5.4 percent drop in demand and the
interest rates are coming up yet the
prices are staying flat do you remember
the big short and there was a two-week
period on wall street where they talked
about why haven't the mark to market
remember why is the bond insurance gone
higher and this gone higher but the
underlying haven't and when it did it
did suddenly so you're seeing the demand
drop and the rates go up well prices are
holding steady those prices are under
stress because of the interest rates and
because the demand dropping and we're
going to i agree with this guy i think
dead ahead you're going to see a sudden
drop in the purchase it's and i think
it's going to be slowly then suddenly
let me just say something i i think um
we talk about the importance of
diversifying where you get
your information we talk about that in
regards to politics all the time we do
say hey if i watch something on cnn i'll
also flip over to fox i don't watch
actual tv i'm talking about youtube i'll
watch clips on msnbc you know cnbc
msnbc fox cnn
uh the whole the whole lot the whole
gamut to get a variety of opinions and
then yeah i can decide for myself
much is the same that where i how i view
my financial advice so
there's like if you only got your advice
from realtors what are realtors going to
tell you it's a great time to buy it
things are always going to go up if
you're if you're only interested in the
stock market you know of course you need
a financial advisor of course you need
someone to manage your money of course
you need to be reinvesting of course you
need to buy the of course like if you're
only talking to somebody who does crypto
it's like bitcoins going to the moon how
do you know you got to get it on bitcoin
you go don't get don't get it it's cheap
so like
it's just
depending on where you get your news is
what you're going to hear so it's
important to kind of hear a a a variety
of sources so you're not influenced to
going down what someone else wants you
to
to do because it benefits their bottom
line yeah i can't tell you how many
realtors i get
like i'm not a big real net real estate
guy although i invest in reits you're
familiar with readers right you can own
real estate without actually having to
get your hands dirty i'm a big fan of
that okay anytime that i do something
here on the pbd podcast or i'm like look
i think kind of buying for most people
is a little overrated hold on shocker
alert depending on where you're at in
life so if you're young if you're single
if you're flexible if you want to have
mobility if you don't you talked about
if you're living in phoenix maybe you're
moving in austin maybe you move miami i
don't know where i'm going stay flexible
like this guy just came from california
the first thing i said to him is like
you've been here about 15 [ __ ]
minutes don't buy right now just rent
okay yeah but at the same time there's
certain people that have families they
have school districts they have you know
they want to
be in a sense of a community they're not
moving anywhere for five ten years cool
bye so but it's always the people that
are like
joe blow real estate bill you know
realtor they're always like you don't
know what you're talking about bro it's
like
by your instagram name i can already
tell you that you're not going to want
to hear what i have to say yeah right
because you're bill realtor yeah okay
johnny mortgage guy
what do you expect to say when someone
talks [ __ ] about your marketplace that's
like pat and i are in the insurance
world right so there's a lot of people
that say you know they're termites don't
buy don't buy universal life don't buy
iul it's a waste of money by term invest
the difference how many times you've
heard that dave ramsey always talks
about that yep so
but at the same time if you interview a
million different insurance agents
they'll tell you the benefits of buying
permanent insurance rather than term
right so just be very careful where you
get your information
from it diversify the content you
consume
diversify the council you're getting on
financial advice diversified i don't
think that's a bad i think that's
actually very good counsel
uh being given to everybody that's
listening to this uh let me let me give
a couple things about comments that
people made one a guy just said scott
rodriguez i believe was the one that
said this
uh scott rodriguez pat my wife and i
were in vegas this past weekend and we
love eating that cut
in the palazzo normally packed and sold
that it was completely empty on a friday
night oh damn and that's the cup okay
and then he says i'll see you in vegas
i'm gonna be there next week okay so
paul i believe cove 12x12 i think his
name is paul i hope it's it's very hard
to pronounce whatever that is but i saw
my home this this time last year sold
the home for way more than it's worth
renting now waiting for the market to
collapse if it does or doesn't i
position myself well good for you what's
that guy's name uh
paul something whatever shout out to
that guy shout out to that guy
you guys were talking about earlier time
i think i think it was pat and you guys
talking about you know the signs and
what you're looking for i mean you guys
i'm gonna be honest made one or two
better decisions than me in life
but you know some of the signs are for
people like me there's a 99 cent store i
walk on lauderdale by the sea i walk in
every single it's a 99 cent store right
everyone has a sticker now it says
dollar twenty five dollar twenty oh
changed that's when you're that's when i
was like wait a minute the dollar
store's gonna have to change its name
inflatable 1.25 and the guy said it's
not going back ever yeah so is that
where you got uh is that where you got
that shirt yeah the shirt and the whole
thing
what they sell shirts now that the
dollar tree
it's a great deal what dude we're not
gonna hate it goodbye yeah why not but i
mean take a look at this yahoo go ahead
no this is a story that's probably near
and dear to your heart you're always
talking about your father yeah that
wasn't 99 yeah so yeah that's how he
made his millions in englewood
one dollar one dollar literally
inflation has dollar stores discount
supermarkets seeing increase in high
income shoppers wow high incomes
discount supermarkets see an increase in
high income shoppers yahoo finance story
how the hell do you know if they're high
income shoppers in the first place like
do they say uh six dollars and 28 cents
but what'd you make last year 220. okay
sounds good go ahead they're like how
many birthday balloons could fit in this
month did they know that
according to consumer price index cpf
figures the food
at home index rose 12.2 percent of the
past year and the overall food index
increased one percent in june bringing
the latter category total increase to
10.4 for the last 12 months and in june
this represents the largest 12-month
increase since the period
ending february of 1981 according to the
bureau of labor statistics these figures
are also higher than the overall
inflation rate which stood at 9.1
percent in turn 90 of americans say they
are concerned about food prices guys
that's a big number 90 percent of
americans say they're concerned about
food prices according to a harris poll
sur survey and by the way this is yahoo
finance it's not fox or cnn
uh uh
the wall street journal reported that
the average spending on grocery products
at discount chains increased 71 percent
let me let me read this one more time to
you did you guys read that wall street
journal reported that the average
spending on grocery products at discount
chains increased
71 from october 2021 to june of 2022.
exactly according to analytics from
in-market and our in-house uh
investigative journalists validated that
right dollar stores discount
supermarkets c shop research this is
aligned with survey for numerometer
which showed that inflation is indeed
changing shoppers habits dollar stores
are seeing more high income shoppers
which is described by people with income
greater than 80 000
who are also switching to save the
numerator survey found that dollar store
sales
are up by about 14
and as the cost of everyday goods
continues to rise consumers are shopping
around to find value this is eric
belcher ceo of numerator
uh many of these shifts include high
income households trading down
uh to dollar stores are unexpected huh
very very interesting
you guys when's the last time you guys
went to a dollar store be honest tom
what's up do you even know what i'm
talking about listen
have you ever seen the food the
groceries in there no it's dude have you
ever heard of a [ __ ] 99 cent store
farm have you ever dude the banana
everything is just disgusting but i mean
people are i've never bought food there
but it's not good i didn't know that
that's old fashioned is that alfonso
remembers his baseball team
it's not good yo the food there is not
good like even the frozen food is like
but like weird pockets but by the way
it's it's stuff like this 71 percent up
so so do you remember like when you're
like
you know uh
people are buying into bitcoin they're
buying into crypto and it's up 71 up 88
like oh should people are buying these
types of things
when it goes 71 percent higher eight
months later at 99 cent stores that's
not a five percent increase or ten
percent increase
something's going on pay attention to
buyer habits
spending habits the way buyers shoppers
are going to 99 cent store there's
either fear that they have that they
want to save their money or something's
going on with their income their
personal lifestyle that's causing 99
cent stores to be up 71 that's crazy
remember when zoom stock went from what
70 bucks to 500 bucks what's it back
down to a hundred bucks yeah okay so
even in the last five years the stock
went from 70 to 100. yeah we looked at
that a week ago that's right 20 22
percent up before and after
zoom went from 70 to 500.
if you're on the correct side of the
ride you made a ride so if 99 cent
stores are up 71 percent ask yourself
why
ask yourself why why that is do any
thoughts on this or no it's been a while
since i've shopped at a nine year old
but i'm not since judging anyone that
does and they're i mean it's packed with
stuff and it's just what do you buy when
you're there toilet paper foil cleaning
stuff like the toilet stuff
it's awesome everything like that bro
that's if you want do i wouldn't
recommend getting food but if you're
gonna go to the dollar store the dollar
tree 100 all the you know paper plates
if you want to throw a party or balloons
every that's the place to go to just i
wouldn't i wouldn't get yogurt or some
[ __ ] like that or me not from the dollar
store can we change it up and go to will
smith story cause i know you got you got
thoughts on this tom so will smith
addresses oscar slap in a new video okay
i don't know but i don't know if we can
play this i don't think we can play this
tyler
so uh uh before the youtube folks show
up i don't know if we can play this or
not but let me read this to you so will
smith
will smith is deeply remorseful about
slapping chris rock at the academy
awards in march smith posted a video on
his instagram account on friday that
began with the words on screen it's been
a minute i was fogged out by that point
smith said it's all fuzzy i've reached
out to chris and the message that came
back from his campus he's not ready to
talk and when he is he will reach out so
i will say to you chris i apologize to
my behavior was unacceptable and i'm
here whenever you are ready to talk
smith also apologizes to rock's mother
family and his brother tony rock
who has stared in 2007 sitcom start in
2007 sitcom all of us which was created
by smith and his wife jada pinkett smith
adam since this is more in your
wheelhouse what are your thoughts on
this
man will i mean what a fall from grace
this guy's had i mean
the even the
the apology tour that he's on right now
was just sad there's nothing manly about
will smith anymore this is [ __ ] will
smith well french fresh prince of bel
air men in black
independence day yup like the the
pursuit of happiness the list goes on
and all he's doing is crying and
apologizing these days
and making amends for his wife banging
some dude dudes okay
dudes i i
number one
uh how long ago was the slap two months
ago no the slap
way but wow four five four months ago no
i was still in l.a no it was may a few
months ago yeah so what took so long and
this is the best you can come up with
i'm just so disappointed with what i'm
seeing with will smith he needs to get
some red pill in his life yeah okay he
needs to get like there's something that
he can do to change his reputation
what's that it's only one thing he needs
to pitch slap someone else and not
apologize to divorce
100 agreement that's the only thing he
can do to change his reputation and i'm
telling you right now because look i'm
i've seen men who were man's men yeah
okay
date a woman and gradually that woman
changed the man okay i read a quote a
long time ago that was given to me
before i was getting married and this is
what the quote said
and i was thinking about getting married
in a different time i wasn't ready and
the guy that gave me the counsel i'm
like yeah this is not a good time for me
to get married quote was a women marry
man
hoping
they change and they don't
men marry women hoping they stay the
same and they don't okay woman change
man stays the same unless if a man
allows a woman to change them
into who he is now today because now
you're scared you're walking on
eggshells
and when a man is in that web they
rarely know they're in that web and they
get destroyed they do they lose their
dna and eventually you're in so deep
that you're convinced you're supposed to
be this person it's treacherous to be in
that situation i think there's only one
thing he can do if he announced tomorrow
that he's filing divorce and he's sick
of it hey love you we had a good run but
i gotta move on and i gotta go live my
life
i will tell you three six twelve months
later everything about his reputation
would would change and people would say
finally he's standing up for himself
that is the only way for him to be out
hundred percent his fans will come back
that he lost will come back will either
needs to go be by himself a little bit
and do some soul searching and i'm sure
he's not going to be biased i'm sure
there's a lineup of plenty of people
that would love to find out what the
principal is up to yeah but at the same
time you know he needs to get somebody
that's crazy about him that wants to be
with him
you know versus the other way around i
think he was crazy about jada versus
jada being crazy about him i think jada
was like yeah i should marry somebody
like a will smith well versus will's
like i'm crazy about her he's got to
find somebody that's crazy about him to
see what that's going to work her first
love was tupac from what i recall so
that's
different so you're not let me ask you
and let me ask you another question yeah
what we haven't talked about maybe
what's the elephant in the room is
hollywood he's as hollywood as it gets
at this point so like
everything about him i just feel is like
okay what what are the people in
hollywood are gonna say how am i gonna
how are they gonna respond to what i'm
doing right now i i mean what's my
career looking like what's the box
office what's the movies yeah what are
the you know the producers saying the
executive producers like everything's
just very calculated it seems
correct you know in hollywood it doesn't
seem to be like yeah i'm the [ __ ] man
i'm do talk [ __ ] about my wife i [ __ ]
how many new projects let me let me ask
you questions let me ask you guys a
question let me ask you guys a question
say jada's dating tupac and they're
married yeah
would that if that would have happened
what does tupac do
in this situation say jade is married to
tupac tupac's alive and they're together
and jade is like oh i had an
entanglement what does tupac do first of
all tupac won't do that interview nope
tupac wouldn't be with her and jada
wouldn't be able to do that to tupac
but what does tupac do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants to he
divorces he hooks up with the honest
girl
the hottest girl that's trending that
he's gonna find actually think about
what tupac would do i mean he cuts her
off he says thanks for you know thanks
for all that you've done you're out the
door we're gonna take a ride with biggie
i'll sit in the middle you sit by the
door
yeah what do you think
like he kills the guy
no no no the buck's not going to kill
the guy tupac is going to make a song
about it oh yeah for sure is going to
make a song about it but he's called him
up yeah he's gone you know he's going to
say hit her up you know you know because
i've moved on that's what the name of
the song is going to be not hit him up
so is there anything that will smith can
do aside from making a song like imagine
that no his song ain't gonna be that i'm
back in miami i'm telling is there
anything he can do aside nothing from
divorcing to regain his reputation
nothing zero no nothing
zero nothing that's again remember it's
my opinion no again nothing but if
you're counseling him you say listen
buddy
i know you've had a good run
it's time to cut it off guys say one
thing about you know you guys know what
that was that that
well-lit production of him saying i'm
sorry that's the studios that's his
agent his manager that's his publicist
saying listen
you're not making the movies right now i
don't know if he is or not we're losing
billions of [ __ ] dollars because
you're not the starring dude because to
be honest with some people don't even
want to go see him right now so that yo
do you see like
he couldn't get the next deal and now
his publicist is like we got to do this
yeah because at the end of the day if
you're going to be a a-list and a
remember when tom cruise had a weird
moment and he gets into it matt lauer on
the pills and then and then was it after
that that he was jumping on oprah's
couch he was in love with love i think
whatever he was
very close first of all tom was right
he was right tom was right yeah i agree
with you tom was right of course he was
right that interview but let me let me
go back to the point you just made and
you kind of given that point about the
fact that
uh uh the publicists are like hey what
are you doing you got to get this job
done okay
there comes a time in your life
where you're
in the goat community and this isn't
this isn't everybody only a few people
get to say this okay in their space will
smith is in the goat status of his space
you know
he's in a goat community of what he did
okay
who gives a [ __ ] what your publicists
say who cares what the fans say who
cares what anybody says bro you killed
it dog like what are you thinking about
like do you realize forget all of us
forget everything what the hell do you
want to do and are you happy inside make
that decision stop listening to freaking
publicist or anybody including us
whatever we're saying make the he knows
what the right decision is make that
decision and move on and stop acting
because that's an act when he got up and
made that video with chris you're acting
like um um you know how they say you
should never do um's and acting it's
acting like um i'm not you know i mean
um
like you're trying to be natural you're
not natural we can tell you're not
you're acting and it's it's very
uncomfortable to even watch us take a
break from everybody
freaking go hang out with monks for a
month do something away from everybody
and decide what you want to do because
the world loved the will who was will
nobody likes a guy that's acting like
trying to be somebody else that the
publicist or the media or the market or
hollywood wants you to be no one's
turned down by that nobody take a page
out of this tate guy that's going viral
why do you think he is going viral
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] what you
think
his background i've never done business
with this guy i don't know what is back
everybody's asking me about what about
this and what about that and what about
this i think most of people in the world
are pissed because how viral he's going
and how much you know what do you call
it how much attention he's getting how
come i'm not getting it the algorithms
are favoring him he's got a better
strategy than you ask yourself will why
is he doing so well
why is he doing something he's an
unapologetic badass that says what's on
his mind that's what will smith needs
but what do the algorithms and the world
say
what do the algorithms and the world say
keep it coming the the algorithms and
the world says that's exactly what we
like yeah we like it
yeah just exactly you remember you
talked about will smith going to hang
out with mom's figuring it out you
remember uh the movie austin powers i
think it was two or three the whole
theme of the movie was i lost my mojo
i can't find my mojo yeah and he just
went like on an escapade around the
world to find the mojo yeah that's
exactly what will smith is missing he's
just
like will smith had that sauce that like
that oh he's got something going on for
a couple decades and now he's just lost
his mojo that'd be something that's
gonna help him find out if somebody
edits that movie with his face on there
that'd be funny
i want to know everybody keeps talking
about will is there anything they can do
to save the kids nobody's talking about
jake what do you mean save the kids
like they're willow they save the kids
nuts they're crazy they're lost they're
way out there far left they're they're
bonkers right and they're sitting there
watching this whole thing play out real
time in front of the world right your
mom and your dad this whole thing's
playing out
let's say
will divorces jada right do you think he
can salvage those like i think the kids
are
are gone like i think they're crazy i
think they've been screwed having to
watch this whole thing play out like how
does this play out for them because
nobody's talking about that
they're not kids anymore yeah
because four years old my parents got a
divorce when i was 10 11 years old i
don't know how old were your parents
when you were i was 20. okay so
you were 20 years old when your parents
got a divorce yes when you got the news
how did you react about [ __ ] time
okay
yeah when i when i got the divorce of
the day my sister graduated
my father yeah my father passed away
when i was 19. cancer and yeah it was
just by me technically it's kind of like
but they never got a divorce they never
got the word
or no no time your parents are they
obviously didn't get a divorce okay so
you know when you're 10 11 and you get
the news you are devastated it plays a
very important role because you need a
father figure so it's kind of like [ __ ]
and i don't have anybody that you know
all that stuff it's a mess okay when
you're at that age
and it forces you to kind of figure
yourself out i saw my dad i didn't see
my dad for a year and a half at the
refugee camp not once i talked to him on
the phone one time
for a year and a half during that 18
month period in the states i sound once
every other week he would come and pick
me up at virgils and i would go spend a
day with them right once every other
week for eight years for six years and
then i joined the army i don't see him
for two and a half years and i come back
and we live together my dad and i okay
to figure out a way to rekindle our
relationship and then boom it just we we
had a run until today he lives with us
and it's one of the best things
decisions that we ever made at that age
yes at this age you know tyler you also
got to know the following
you know the saying whenever i go to a
city and somebody's like from uh uh
barbados it's like hey what is it like
growing up in barbados i always love the
answer they give you know what's my
favorite answer i don't know anything
different this is the only thing i know
right so when you're raised in a poor
family guess what's the only thing you
know poor poor when you raise a middle
income when you're raising a divorce
family that's like when you raise with
parents being together that's all you
know when you raise going to church
that's all you know when you're raised
in hollywood from day one that you're
born and your mom and your dad are
famous and everywhere they talk about
them they trade them royally you don't
know anything different they're used to
this they're well-trained people
to live the life that they live and for
them it's all art and creativity they're
going to be okay my concern is in them
they're going to be fine
if they were messed up they were messed
up because of the first 10 years of the
way they were raised not because of how
they're going to be raised what do you
think about like kanye's kids i kind of
get what you're pointing like i've seen
kanye west right now they're walking
yeah because they're young
and they're acting like like they're
acting crazy too right now that's
different but believe it or not connie
has got
kanye is in a strange way he's teaching
the right values and principles in a
strange way it is what it is he's
aligned with uh
with god yeah for sure but i number one
i just checked there jayden smith is 24
years old willow smith is 21 like
like pat said it's from zero to 10 that
really shapes you and maybe it up up
until you're a teenager but at this
point
it is what it is i actually happen to
think that the kids are very talented
are they far left woke whatever you want
to kind of put on them politically sure
have at it but as far as talent goes
those kids are unquestionably talented
jayden smith has a song called icon that
is classic amazing awesome song
regardless um willow smith i think had a
uh
i weighed my head about like whatever
her head like when she was like 14 years
old
beyond talented so but
to pat's point or your point
the younger you are like kanye's kids
whoever like those kids are going to
have very impressionable very they're
careful
that's a different story that's a
different story will
bottom line it's time for you to take a
leap of faith and go on your own yeah
hey quick moment i know you guys are not
sports guys but bill russell passed away
uh yesterday and the rest in peace two
days ago rest in peace bill russell to
one the greats of all time amen some
call them the great some put them in the
top five top ten of the list eleven
championships was a coach
crushed it going up against will
chamberlain for god knows how many years
and one of the most respectable guys in
the entire sports
uh a world nba of course but all sports
everybody respect brady commented on
this guy everybody commented on him
yesterday
uh may he rest in peace if you judge
goats
champions by championships he's
unquestionably the greatest of all teams
if that's how you judge uh
performers athletes performances so all
right let's go into uh nancy pelosi's
visit and the comments coming back from
china and what that's looking like okay
so
nancy pelosi to visit taiwan despite
warnings from china uh house speaker
nancy pelosi is planning to visit taiwan
with meetings scheduled with government
officials on the self-ruled island that
china claims as its own raising the
prospect of increased tensions between
u.s and china people whom pelosi is
planning to meet with in taiwan have
been informed for her imminent arrival
though
some details remain in flux some of the
pelosi's meetings have been scheduled
for tuesday evening but most are set for
wednesday which include but aren't
limited to taiwanese government
officials chinese president xi jinping
warned biden in a phone call thursday
that the u.s must not play with fire on
taiwan
those who play with fire will perish by
it it is hoped that the u.s will be
clear-eyed about this first of all
how do you feel
about
xi jinping
telling the leader of the world
joe biden
to to your plane with fire and those who
play with fire will perish by it
it is hoped that the us will be
clear-eyed about this direct threat
direct threat 100 100 that's a threat
how do you feel about this so first of
all how do you feel what should what
should nancy do should she still go
uh what do you think about the threat
and how should how should biden handle
this i'm asking all those three
different questions i'll go to you first
adam and tom will come to you next look
uh
let's let's just put politics aside i
don't care what side of the aisle you on
this is the number three person in line
for the presidency of the united states
i don't care if this is nancy pelosi i
don't care if this is who's the last
republican speaker of the house paul
ryan and who was before that uh jim john
whoever it is
if a representative of the united states
wants to go visit taiwan a full-on
democracy regardless of what china says
they should be able to go and and what
kind of
image or precedent would this set to the
world
if
she was planning on making a visit
and xi jinping says don't go or you'll
really piss us off
and they don't go
what kind of precedent does that send to
the rest of the world or especially the
united states here again put politics
aside this is a representative of the
united states of america by the way you
know who's co-signing on a lot of uh
telling her to go a lot of republicans
it's not just for 100 absolutely a lot
of republicans who are basically yes
saying we don't like what china is doing
this is an american issue what's
happening with china china is our number
one foe some may call it an enemy some
may call it a threat whatever you want
to label china
and credit to donald trump because he
made china top of the list of our frame
of reference for understanding what
they're doing to our country who did
trump yeah
okay
so
i applaud nancy for going and if if xi
ji let's let's see what kind of
ramifications happen for this
i don't know the now what i will say i
don't know the reason that she's going
is it a diplomatic mission is she there
to speak with
uh the prime minister
is there an agenda there is a trade
agreement is it talk about defense the
south china sea
and and
the way i'm uh processing this
whatever the reason
she has the
the right to go visit taiwan okay
so i'm totally cool with this and it'll
send a message i think a soft power
message saying oh you don't want us to
do something china go [ __ ] yourself i'll
see you in taiwan next week that's my
thoughts tom
well i think z
does not want any legitimization of
taiwan or any support for taiwan so he
wants to block that at all cost and he
is not testing the united states of
america he knows better he is testing
joe biden
period he is testing biden and by the
way this trip with some of the agenda
this is a secretary of state trip this
is not a speaker of the house trip so
if there's some reason for her to be
there there's some
trade agreements industry alignments
whatever it is okay i agree if she wants
to go go she's not like you know a small
freshman congressman from montana she's
the freaking sec she's freaking speaker
of the house representing the majority
and so she is absolutely legitimate to
go and i think what z is doing he
is trying to draw this box around taiwan
with perception with the u.n with
everything else i'm going to do it it's
just a matter of when and you got to get
good with this that's what he's doing
with all of his actions
and he's testing joe biden period do you
think
that phone call gets made to donald j
trump
hell no hell no hell no
yeah exactly so so did you i thought you
were going to say something else go
ahead vinnie because i got some thoughts
i want to hear you okay so here's what i
would say number one
um
i hope she goes
okay and i hope she takes a stand and
she goes and whether it's a legacy move
she's 80 something right now and she
wants to go you know
for her to
you know whether you agree with a person
or not politically whether she wants to
make her grandkids proud or to say my
grandma had the audacity and the courage
to go to taiwan during the time where
she was threatened for her life salute
to your aspirations hundred percent go
100 get what's yours i respect that
especially in your 80s i know people who
are in their 60s that don't want to go
10 miles down to go sit down with
somebody this woman is willing to get on
a plane in her 80s to go to taiwan with
death threats behind it listen agree or
disagree more power to you respect okay
number two
let's talk foreign policy okay for those
of you that uh thought uh foreign policy
you know you know how you
you uh uh oh
you're you're raising a family where
there's food and there's bed and there's
a roof above your head and you're like
but we didn't have this
you know like people say pat you never
played organized sports you're massive
you're this i'm like dude i was working
every day after you know school i went
straight to haagenaz i had a job i had
to figure out a way make money we had no
money but dude you were bodybuilding i
was but i had to figure out a way to
make money fine
but man like you grew up poor no not by
my side i had a bed
my mom fed me had a place to live never
rained on our bed totally grateful for
it very happy went to the army had the
time of my life got out luckiest man i
like to live in america i'm very happy
right okay great
when
for four years nothing happens with
foreign policy and you don't go to sleep
with any threats
that's the best thing that happens when
it does for you to sit there and say
who the hell was threatening us with
things like this okay do you know that
phone call that xi jinping made you know
who made that phone call three years ago
and everybody said trump was getting
close to the north korea leader four
years ago you know what he told the
north korea leader do you guys remember
what he told to north korea came down
with fire and fury in ways you've never
seen before yeah so xiching bank was
field trained by donald trump
i think so he took that script away from
trump and he used it on bite now why
would he use it on bite now let me ask
you a question
um
you ever gone into a fight with somebody
many times okay when you do get into a
fight with somebody
and you feel pretty confident what do
you tell the guy when you feel pretty
confident i'm gonna whoop your ass okay
will you say what say something say
something i'm gonna
who would you not say that to somebody
that i don't think i could beat up
[Laughter]
so so for example let's just say you're
in you're in a club
and you're talking to a girl and gsp
comes and starts talking to the same
girl and i know it's jesus and he knows
gsp
you say what you say listen mary
don't go for it
i'm gay i'm gay
i'm gay gsp
okay so the point is nobody makes it
nobody nobody makes threats to anybody
unless if they know yeah they go up
their ass and and if you you do you do
like you think she would say something
like that to a person that they don't
think they can make that threat to no so
that means he is very confident he can
make that threat
by the way trump i don't think he says
that to any of our last four presidents
i don't think i don't think he says it
to obama i don't think he says it too
but but i don't think george bush
because cheney would be like can i blow
him up please please
that's that's all it is that's all i
need it's a threat
right yeah so so
watch this now foreign this
take take your top enemies everybody has
enemies you got haters i'm not talking
haters i'm talking enemies yeah okay
so
what's the imagine your top two biggest
enemies at the top of the leaders
bulletin take your biggest enemies in
your life you ever had okay
ever not haters enemies direct enemies
that are taking market share away from
you
one day you wake up with some of us
experiences about two weeks ago one day
you wake up your top two enemies unite
oh great
when you win that's what you meant
when you wake up and you're like wait
what
yup goes to united holy [ __ ] okay what
did we do well here's an article to read
and your general defect
exactly like voltron
so watch this here this is an article
today yesterday russia is with you putin
vows to back xi
in u.s row over taiwan visit now go a
little lower because i want to read what
the china's
there's a general all the way in the
bottom keep going lower look for the
general that's uh named z keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going oh by the way that's the video let
them see that video click on that and
look what's turning that's a moscow
okay
hey
we're with you that's enough wow okay
we're with you that's a red square that
is is that just that wow yes we're with
you we got you don't worry about it what
tv tower right now
china russia is with you hardly can
happen without an official approval
context needs no explanation okay so
what are they saying now if you go all
the way to the bottom of the article
above pelosi's picture right there
zao told the regular daily briefing we
would like to tell the united states
once again that china is standing by the
chinese people's liberation army will
never sit idly by and china will take
resolute responses and strong counter
measures to defend its sovereignty and
territorial integrity okay
so bring you back to us on the camera uh
for us to be talking about this all
right so
iran historically has had a reputation
of
saying they're going to do something and
they don't to america if you do this
we're going to do this if you do that
we're going to do this like hey they
took soleimani and what happened they
bombed the base that nobody was at the
base exactly just to say we retaliated
and we are going to fight for a person
now
iran will take vengeance during their
time but how long that could take we
don't know you remember the threats they
made against trump recently no question
they said that they're trying to kidnap
trump basically yeah so right i'm not
making that up i know this is two weeks
ago yeah i know i know but but this is
the part that's the part that gets me
thinking with this one here
there there's a few things in life you
have to be very careful with
if you have a reputation everybody in
life at one point made a threat that
they didn't deliver everybody you know
like you know you'll go to
i swear to god i'm going to blow this
place up you're just pissed off
let me say that one more time watch what
i'm going to do i'll never come back
here again i'll see you next time
right here
okay but i tell you if there is one
thing like jennifer knows one thing i
tell you like jennifer knows one thing
if i say
we'll never come back to this restaurant
again ask jennifer for the last 15 years
of her night being together look what
she'll tell you just ask her you've
never been back just ask what she'll
tell you okay just ask so i wanted to
buy this you can call it whatever you
want to call it i want to buy the sushi
restaurant because we were in glendale
and they said no the person that we were
in uh granada hills you know which
restaurant i'm talking about down the
street from i don't want to say the name
but some people know what it's a sushi
spot
it's a great place your private
chopsticks
this was 15 years ago and i love this
place
and i said i would like to buy this
place
and this i'm sorry we can only sell it
to one of our uh our kind so what do you
mean i can't sell it to you because
humans mean humans you're not human
iranian they wanted somebody to buy
that's there and she says it to my face
wow
i i said i can't come back here man i
just can't come back here right so
restaurants so she'll tell you pat i can
give you 20 restaurants that that
happened to i value service and i
because i give service i value service
on return okay perf you can call it
whatever you want i'm very comfortable
in my own skin this is who i am i'm
comfortable with this part
in life
if you make threats
and you don't keep them
people eventually just
know that you're a guy that just does a
lot of talking
no one is a hundred percent delivered
under threats nobody's 100 delivered
under threats nobody because if a
hundred percent of threats were met we
wouldn't be living today be armageddon
and this place wouldn't exist okay thank
god a hundred percent of threats have
not been kept in the world just so you
know okay
having said that
if you come out this strong and your
name is china
and you want to be the world leader
you cannot make a threat like this and
not deliver wow
which means
she has to know this
biden has to know this
we have to be on alert and we have to
know this isn't a small country saying
this
this isn't a billionaire saying this
this is our number one enemy in the
world who wants to take over us they had
a vision called made in china 2025 it
was by 2025 china wanted to be the ruler
of the world
when they say this
you best believe behind closed doors
everybody needs to be ready for this so
now let's flip it so let's just say
there's there's they're having calls
behind closed doors i want to ask you
guys a question and audience for those
of you that are listening to this i want
to hear your thoughts on your commentary
let's now flip it there's a meeting
generals are sitting there and one of
the generals says
president biden uh uh
speaker pelosi
you know what's the rvp's name uh
kamala harris
hey
nobody knows the vp
so if she's even into rooms so let's
just say
hey we don't think this is a good idea
and we don't think you need to make this
trip and we need to talk to the media
about telling a different kind of a
story that a health matter came up or
something happened but you cannot go to
taiwan right now because china is very
serious now
if pelosi pulls out of this visit to
taiwan how do you process it yourself
that's the question z1 and we found a
reason not to go and a weak
administration let it go how do you see
it
well
first of all the fact that
they own us right we that to them more
than anything you can't japan is more
than china japan is point one trillion
china we're really close too yeah but
they like how many just just the threats
the the fact i think that we owe them we
can't do we they they're in charge bro
you get and so here's my question due to
a pet so they threatened her just
personally they didn't threaten us just
as a country like there's going to be a
blow back from all threat is very
general the threat is actually not
directed towards pelosi my
interpretation english is my fifth
language but from my understanding
they're saying if she shows up she
represents america we have to retaliate
not to pelosi like they're not going to
go slasher tires they're going to
retaliate to us those who play with fire
will perish exactly and those that
that's that's that's a that's a threat
but pelosi doesn't go how do you process
it uh she's going
to 100 that she's gone i i think
uh she is going
i think heard and biden had a full-on
conversation
and
they decided yes you are going you're
going to show strength and go to taiwan
and let's see what happens here
i don't think there's any question that
president biden and nancy pelosi had a
conversation and they process all the
positives and negatives of doing this
and they decided go for it
and i'm sure there's going to be
breaking news today
that because she i think she's on her
way right now are you aware of that yes
she's like she's on her way it's not
like well maybe next week but she's on
her way i thought that was a uh i
thought they went and they have a refuel
and that's like
so and i get what you're saying so you
guys so it okay i understand it's ballsy
it's showing a message is it worth
because if they're if they do step up to
their threat like you were just talking
about then what we're willing to risk a
war because this eighty five-year-old
[ __ ] wants to go to like taiwan i don't
think like what do we i don't think you
don't care about that be careful with
that you may not we may not like her but
she's not an 85 year old [ __ ] she is
the speaker of the house she is an
american diplomat we may disagree with
her politically but this is one of those
conversations
he's just someone but but you should put
me off but but that's also that's also
something that is very important to
understand this is an american thing
yeah and i'm not picking on you here
that's the type of mentality that is is
is dividing america not you brother yeah
no but like some 85 year old [ __ ] no an
american diplomat is going to taiwan
stop to show strength a lot worse things
than about carelessness
a long time ago on this podcast is
respect like you know that kind of stuff
let's set that aside he's using it with
his language go back when you're talking
about when she's in north korea i wasn't
like some [ __ ] went to the present
united states went to north korea and
stepped over
the disengagement line okay like at some
point you have to put bipartisan
politics aside and say this is an
american issue this is not the you
you're you're so i think she's going
differently she's going yes right now
i'm looking at bloomberg's story so you
were checking it's a bloomberg
pelosi poised to land in taiwan as china
rips provocative trip okay and okay and
and what do you think china is going to
do they're going to send out some
warships
they're what they're probably gonna
fly some planes in the sky like they're
gonna send a message but it's gonna be
bluster yeah well just
hopefully it's not not a virus that
comes out of a wet market that comes
here let's just hope that doesn't happen
i actually because i think that's a very
valuable then all of a sudden like you
know cloven you actually have a very
valid point yeah that's what i'm saying
so is it worth her going there like what
like i just don't understand the the
urge oh just to make a question that's a
good question you're asking as well it
is a fair question to ask it doesn't
mean like again
they the one that when the press
secretary was being interviewed she said
she's going for her own reasons like the
the the what's what's his name said this
i tell you exactly who said this saint
peter jean-pierre no no no no i'm sorry
the guy said it not john kirby no um
well because remember the speaker for
the the pentagon came out and said we do
not support
taiwan like we do not support taiwan as
a thank you as its own nation
that's a big
statement john kirby the speaker for the
pentagon he said we do not support
taiwan do you realize like what the hell
is going on
you know if they say we do not support
taiwan what's next
like imagine them coming out and saying
we do not support israel what do you
mean we do not support taiwan we do not
support israel we do not support so this
is a slippery slope on what could
potentially happen next because you're
bowing down and you're afraid now
zero give me your percentage of china
this goes based on the question he asks
because again this is dialogue here that
we're having so go to um
uh what is the likelihood
of china retaliating and i'm gonna ask a
question the following way
what is the likelihood of china
retaliating immediately
versus china retaliating long term
so if you were to say 10 percent chance
they retaliate immediately 90 chance
they do something long term what would
you say those percentages i actually
agree with those odds i don't think
anything short term is going to happen i
don't think there's going to be anything
possible yeah i mean and remember how
they retaliate you were
there are three fronts to the
alternative war conventional wars always
last and conventional wars got
conventional war and then conventional
nuclear war those are last then you have
you know tech war right
cyber yeah exactly all the cyber things
you can do
second you have bio and then you have
economic and those are the three fronts
in the new war and what we really
haven't seen
is bio but if you listen to any of the
pentagon speakers that talk about the
modern threat matrix
bio is out there because it's one of the
most easiest to deploy
um and you would wait you know as i said
long ago revenge is a meal best served
cold uh to avoid you know to avoid
another retaliation against you and so
that's that's a front whether it's cyber
or it's bio or economic i think china's
going to retaliate does the virus fall
under bio yes okay so when joe biden
goes a second pandemic is definitely
coming this is the type of [ __ ] that
makes another pandemic just randomly
having pat and just just to clarify you
know what like you know some people
throw
throw away the word hey [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] when's the lot when you see nancy
pelosi on stage in the state of the
union with trump ripping you know
speeches when she talks to reporters
she's she acts like a [ __ ] when
somebody goes hey you're insider do you
ever give your you know your husband
information whatever she walks away and
i was in her office anybody that whips
and handcuffs her husband to me is a
[ __ ] but we don't have that kind of
experience you've been i did
to your point
if those are the three
criteria for war
those are the three more
more exactly forms of war before a hot
war okay and you said before
conventional war which is correct easy
to end up in a in a stalemate so see
ukraine here's my q exactly uh here's my
question for the biz doc you said um
economic you said bio and you said cyber
correct aren't we already in a full-on
those three-prong war with china we're
in an economic warfare with them right
now
bio we talked about kovid i mean that's
they've created war on the world
you know i'm not even being pc here it
came from china still haven't held them
accountable by the way
and as far as uh what was the third
sorry tech cyber we've been dealing with
china cyber hacking
for years now so
whether you want to define it as a war
or not those are three things that we're
already dealing with in china especially
the economic side of things and recently
now bio and cyber has been going on for
a while so you know news flash we're
already at war with china
correct
and what they're talking about is
elevated spikes of really damaging
intensity guys reuters story just came
up can you pull that up please this one
here
yeah exactly the one i just said oh do
you pull that up at the same time that's
crazy i just texted you
chinese warplanes take to skies this
just was given nine minutes ago guys
this this was just just went up a few
minutes ago
u.s warships on move before expect a
pelosi visit to taiwan
but they're busting the straight they're
not they're not in the air space you see
buzzing the straight that's been the
chinese thing they're rolling armored
vehicles down like they
i don't know
evacuate or get home people in bathing
suits are just making room for the tanks
look at this that's hilarious latest
footage circulating on chinese social
media wechat shows
what is that armored vehicles on the
move in southern chinese city of
xiaomi i think there's lots of show like
they had a big parade you know showing
their you know their soldiers and stuff
like that but i mean you never know
right i mean this could be on the onion
right it's like all right chinese
citizens bottom line are you okay with
this move remember going to taiwan well
we'll know in an hour
yeah
i'm not joking i mean this is
am i am i okay with it yeah let's ask
the question a different way
um
oh interesting for the website of
government type one also suffered a
brief outage tuesday due to cyber uh
attack where generations i don't think
people would really like spikes serious
stuff this is just going like this we
can do something bigger yeah so what
tyler was going to say i didn't what
would you say no i just i don't think
people realize how deeply entrenched and
how powerful the chinese are like this
isn't we shouldn't be worried about the
warplanes and the warships and the
armored vehicles no they can take down
whatever they want to take down at a
minute's notice they can literally stop
the economy so can we though they export
i we are so reliant on china they don't
think we have the power to like us no uh
this
no under under a person that's willing
to put sanctions and play aggressive yes
you can't a biden cannot play he cannot
play those games
his personality is not that personality
bro but
that's different from capabilities of
what the united states
can power this all be the most dominant
center in the league and all of a sudden
get pissed off like shaq and go through
around his weight no
it's a different style right pal is a
different style than chat but that's
different that's my question is
capabilities you know no the pentagon
regardless still has the same exact
capabilities there's then they do under
obama bush
the word capabilities is one thing
the other one is when a nation has been
buying people up for decades
and playing their politics game
better than anybody else and getting so
many the major corporation relying on
them to produce their products their
chips
everything air conditioning so many we
can go down you know the list we don't
need this like
medicine yeah so all of this stuff that
they produce yeah no it's the other way
around so
um respect to her for going i i'm not
sure if the timing is a good timing why
because
this is interpretation say we have
nothing you say we're not say we to pick
a country that's got nothing to do with
what's going on right now and they're by
themselves pick a country new zealand
okay i'll just say they're just like
sitting in new zealand there's a there's
a podcast in new zealand what was that
was it me oh [ __ ] oh
okay say we got a podcast in new zealand
and new zealand's like oh [ __ ] what's
going on you know what's going on over
there with the u.s china all this other
stuff here's what they're going to be
saying so let me get this straight
um
first you go after ukraine
and putin told you don't
and you guys try to get nato to get
close so ukraine could be and they're on
my southern border and i told you don't
do it
because you want to have a better
relationship with me
and then you go after
taiwan
what the hell are you guys doing
when when what did you say uh two days
ago with you and chris we don't need to
tell the whole story but there was a
one of your girlfriends and he said the
two-week business you know you know what
i'm talking about business it was a
business arrangement right but why was
it a business arrangement it's a revenge
business arrangement yeah we got to get
even right let's not get him i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get
into the story but the point is we gotta
get even right okay fair
um you don't think china and russia are
saying we gotta get even though
i don't think timing was good i think
timing is a bit off of her if it's for
her legacy whatever she goes they do
whatever they do she'll be able to write
that in her book
um
but but i think while ukraine and russia
is still going on and then you do it
then i don't know i i just don't know if
i'm
sequencing is key i think this is out of
whack sequencing
that's all i'm thinking about well i
think this raises a bigger question do
we support taiwanese independence do we
support taiwan as a sovereign country
what do you mean do we support that for
years we've been saying yes all of a
sudden you want to change it yesterday
and say no that's what i'm saying kirby
came out and said no we don't but but i
i believe taiwan is very different than
ukraine ukraine i believe taiwan is a
serious ally i believe their exports are
monumentally important to the us
you can make like i'm asking somebody to
make a case you're talking about huh
semiconductor semiconductors exactly
like eight it's
absurd amount of semiconductors export
and imagine they stop exporting them
everything stops technology ends no more
cars no more computers no more fridges
with that
imagine if china is controlling all of
that and we people have been concerned
about 5g i'm not talking about the
conspiracy theorists talking about
health i'm talking about all of the 5g
networks have been built
with
chinese components that people have been
concerned
about embedded technology in those
components that can route data back
and if you think that tick tock is bad
with bike dance and things going on
there and joe rogan said yeah the fine
print just says all your data and all
your keystroking is going to china so if
you think that's bad and 5g is bad
imagine if they control
80 percent of the
world's semi-conductor production you
don't think infiltration is easy and you
don't think
it's it's a whole different level of
espionage whole different level
yeah i mean it's it's wild so
again this is why 70 75 market share of
semiconductor production is it's i yeah
i think it's got to be close to 80 right
yeah it's it's crazy and and this is why
people were working so hard to make the
case for it don't
don't send 50 billion dollars to ukraine
don't make russia an enemy where we
don't have to we didn't russia saying we
have your back china was it could have
been prevented we could have had russia
the enemy of my enemy is my friend
russia and china were never meant to be
allies they they oppose each other and
they always will oppose each other when
it comes down to it
but all we're doing is pushing ukraine
why do they oppose each other i know
that they're on each other's border and
they've had some long-standing issues
because china wants to do i feel like we
push them into each other's arms for
decades now we have okay i'm not this is
anything new no but china sees russia as
its helpful nephew not its son
that's china sees russia
as its nephew yeah as a helpful nephew
right
not as not as their son not as blood
they see it as
they're gonna help me out they're using
ever played there's an old old board
game that's really good that's had a
surge in popularity called diplomacy and
if you ever played that game and
everybody in the chat has played that
game that's what's going on right now
right china is using
russia as this helpful force
that's what's going on here
period
china is using russia as a helpful
helpful force yeah like a helpful
diplomatic force and by the way russia's
got tons of energy china's got to get
energy from somebody that's one thing
china doesn't have right
of all the things that china has it does
not have
the ability with its size and sk scale
to truly be energy independent so it's
got to have energy allies
period
enter russia and russia is russia's
biggest energy oh yeah
yeah and russia's is basically you look
at look at look at german economy
they're
they were worried that an ongoing
conflict could result in natural gas
shortages for two consecutive winners so
germany was very concerned about what
was going on in ukraine and not from a
political standpoint but from a from
just that you know that
the ability to have the energy to power
germany through the winter
interesting
but also i mean you're familiar with
what the quad is
the quad the quad so basically there's
an alliance between united states of
america
uh japan
australia and india i thought of this
because you brought up new zealand
because you know as you were like uh new
zealand doesn't have anything to do with
this i think of new zealand as like a
little nephew to australia
they've created something called the
quad to basically
deal with china's influence in the south
china sea so there's a defense mechanism
against china out there so
i think the the the question remains
here is what do we do about the china
problem do we tell them
you know
we'll do what they say we don't
take a stand against them we're scared
of their rhetoric we don't do something
it's
this is the question that is gonna be
basically we're gonna have to answer for
the next decades to come
russia on the other hand i mean how many
other countries other the united states
are supporting uh
ukraine
the majority of them now a lot of
countries right it's not just the united
states i think the people people
for you know that are not familiar but
basically everyone in the eu has
supported them by one way or another
absolutely and we just sent them what
500 how much did we spend yesterday 500
million yeah another one
we've sent a good uh large chunk of it
let me read a couple of years
as provided uh funds first let me read a
couple comments here so super chats anas
china has us by the balls they do they
own our tech
have back door to it and their army is
strong our army does not know their
gender
we the american people don't want war
let the politicians kids
and them go uh vince said we're in the
end of days prepare your hearts uh jesus
christ is our lord okay great thank you
vince thank you for that okay scott
rodriguez loved this podcast seriously
the best podcast on youtube scott you
the man
scotty edward snowden said we can shut
any country down with a click of a mouse
uh paul is back this administration is
tone deaf horrible instincts people
don't have enough to
like trump but at least his instincts
were tuned in
tom you got it wrong with bricks uh
dropped us dollar
america has been oppressing the world
since 1991 russia and china want to
bring down the dollar and replace it
with metals like gold copper and lithium
what do you think about that
that's part of the economic war right
i think that's what he's talking about
and then vince said silver and gor gold
are the only real minds left i own 500
000
worth and i hold it in my home don't
fool yourself prepare now vince make
sure that doesn't target your house and
people won't know where you're at
what's your address that's your address
exactly to come over for a million
dollars i'll give you my head yeah but
the local gang i give you some more gold
baby yeah why not the first comment um
about how our military doesn't know if
they're man and woman
i think that's a hyperbolic uh yes there
is a little woke little tiny problem
going on i don't think it's as bad i
think the people in the military have
utmost respect for our
uh military community and i think it's a
disservice to be like they're all
woke and they're transgender all about
like
you've served in the military you've
served in the military
he's got a point though the guys doing
the work may not but the guys at the top
are being too woke and too diplomatic
and
military there's a few things that
shouldn't be diplomatic okay
military should be we're the military
that's it leave us alone get the hell
out of here you know let us play the
world that we play you guys go play the
business game the money game the
whatever stuff that you guys do let us
do the war game and then if you want to
find out come and join us you know see
if you can handle this or not but let us
be you do not want your military to be
extremely sensitive walking on eggshells
that's the last thing you want like the
last thing you want right and there's a
few other places you don't want that to
be the case so there is a part of the
comment he's making that he's right
we're trying to please too many people
china could care less about what you
think about him get in line get an order
this is the formation you're fighting
for your country
america's the enemy protect it that's
what matters let's make sure china
becomes the greatest country in the
world by 2025.
that's their vision america's like well
look yes
you know this whole concept about
america is the greatest country in the
world we don't know maybe it is
somewhere else maybe it's chile you know
maybe it is china maybe it is oh my gosh
stop it there's power and affirmations
and china's win the affirmation game
right now uh with their own people
america's not winning the affirmation
game right now
do you know what i mean by the
affirmation game yeah of course
words have power is what you're saying
words have a lot of cutting beliefs
limiting beliefs absolutely okay so
monkey pox all right let's talk about
this interesting it's you know
some thought i wasn't going to get a lot
of attention some are saying it is
getting attention now so new york city
officials declare monkey pox a public
health
emergency this is an msn story new york
city officials declare monkey pox
republican emergency on saturday in an
effort to respond more efficiency
efficiently to the current outbreak
which may begin in may which began in
may san francisco was the first u.s city
to declare a state of emergency to
combat the monkey pox outbreak last week
in a joint statement new york city mayor
eric adams and dr ashwin vassan
commissioner of the city health and
mental hygiene department said that new
york is currently the epicenter of the
monkey pox outbreak in the u.s and the
estimate that about approximately 150
000 new yorkers may currently be at risk
of them by the way only 50 800 cases
what are they talking about yeah both
officials also said that the outbreak
must be met with urgency action and
resources both nationally and globally
and that the declaration reflected the
seriousness of the moment as of august
1st the new york city health department
has reported
1472 cases of monkey pox i heard a
couple of things uh this morning when i
was listening to the news uh first of
all they only have 300 and i think 50 uh
vaccines available for it it doesn't
kill you and it's only really really
rampant in the gay community which i
don't even know how like
it just popped out of nowhere the guy
was like it's not like an age it's not
gonna kill anybody so it's not like it
shouldn't be like oh my god but they
have they have limited amount of
vaccines for this even though we do have
sun and there's only one small is it
dutch i mean get that wrong one small
dutch comp company that's actually uh
that makes it happen
the chat can correct me or tyler you can
look that up but i think there's only
one small dutch company that's making
the vaccine oh really
i gotta tell you we're gonna invest in
that on them tom let's get on that i
don't i don't call it like
covet fatigue whatever
like
i'm hearing about just like i don't got
no ain't nobody got no time for your
monkey pops up and you gotta i ain't got
going to the [ __ ] zoo
i don't gotta i'm not dealing with
smallpox monkey pox
i'm not dealing with tupac none of it
i'm dealing with i'm done i like i see
the monkey pox pop up i'm like all right
keep it moving i'm gonna i'm not gonna
front though i did see some videos about
where the guy some guy was like on a
world star and he was talk bro it looks
really really bad i wouldn't want it i'm
sure but he was just like yeah man i
just you know was that a uh it was a
weird story he's like i was at a i don't
i'm not trying to be funny yeah there's
not like a
sexual origin type situation goes you
know i was making out a bunch of guys
and i got it and then he goes like eight
other guys in the place got it and i was
a guy
yeah i was going to show you this these
are the vaccine requirements in new york
city you can only be vaccinated if you
meet the following conditions gay
bisexual or other man who has sex with
men 18 or older have had multiple or uh
anonymous sex partners in the last 14
days um you should consider getting
vaccinated if you met partners through
online applications such as grind or
tinder or have a condition that may
increase your risk for severe death if
infected with monkey pox such as hiv is
there a phone number for this why is
this a public emergency like maybe in
new york i get it but you're going to
see i think you're just looking again
pull up that article please i just said
that this is not something i'm paying
attention to but this seems to be
running rampant in the gay community is
that what's going on specifically men
yeah which is kind of i don't even know
what it comes out of like here guys
here's a cm when's the last time you
would you would expect c and no show the
logo at the top left so they know who
are this is a cnbc story
world health organization recommends gay
and bisexual men limit sexual partners
to reduce the spread of monkey pox
zoom in a little bit to read some of
this
zoom in a little bit to read some of
this men who have sex with men are the
highest risk of infection right now for
monkey pox about 99 of cases are among
men and at least 95 of those patients
are men who are having sex with other
men according to
world health organization ted rose
said men who have sex with men should
consider limiting their sexual partners
to lower their risk of infection reduce
their spread the world health
organization chief called on media
public health authorities and government
to fight stigma and discrimination which
you said will only fuel the outbreak
well there goes my weekend
just messing around but like it just
came out of nowhere but but notice how
they were trying to make it like it was
another pandemic no it's not bro it's
only targeting a serving group can you
scroll back did it say 99 of cases or
with uh men hooking up with men
scrolling that's guys yeah i mean i'm
not even being sarcastic i'm not like if
you're a gay man slow down and this is
what you're dealing and this is you
should be concerned yeah 100 and i i
implore you to act accordingly yeah okay
nobody wants anybody to get sick nobody
wants to get these diseases
um
you're at risk yep for the for the other
you know
rest of us
carry on exactly
keep your calm and carry on you're good
oh my god
okay all right
i don't want to hear any more about okay
there's something like what
reveal what the frustration was please
i'm not going to but it's it's it's it's
um
it's it's a little bit too much right
now man this is just ridiculous what
what they're doing
the topic the topic in common sense and
walking on egg shows is out of control
today of what people have to
i can't even believe what i just read
right now is what i'm reading like this
is this has become normal but hey at
least we can identify what a man is yeah
i mean i'm not i'm not even going in
that direction but it's like
yeah
uh let's just let's just go to this
other story about uh uh uh uh
very very
pat is very rarely uh
in the brain
monkey wrench great play on words monkey
wrench with the monkey pod like i got a
lot to say yeah but i'm not going to say
nothing but i got a lot to say and i'm
not going to say nothing on this topic
here
you just we just read it for you now
you're informed good for you make the
right decision folks okay i'll be smart
all right schumer uh let's talk about
the mansion mansion says republicans in
normal times will be supporting energy
health health care bill this is a cnn
story
democrat senator joe manchin argued
sunday that republicans would in normal
time support and energy and health care
bill he recently negotiated with elite
with the leaders of the party i think
it's great piece of legislation and on
normal times my republican colleagues
would have been uh
something such as this we basically pay
down the debt
which is what they want we've
accelerated permitting which is what
they want and we've increased production
of energy which is what they want
we've done things that we should be
doing together mansion also defended the
provision in a bill that would impose a
15 minimum tax on certain corporations
these are the bigger corporations out
there and they said taxes won't be going
up but i think it is going up schumer
mansion deal
raises taxes on earners under four
hundred thousand dollars the energy and
health care bill
from mansion and schumer would raise
taxes on millions of americans earning
less than four hundred thousand dollars
annually uh senate republican says
citing nonpartisan data the
congressional joint committee on
taxation found that taxes would jump by
16.7 billion dollars on american payers
making less than 200 000
in 2023 and raise another 14.1 billion
on taxpayers who make between two to
five hundred thousand dollars during the
ten year window the average tax rate
would go up for most american categories
by 2031 new energy credits and subsidies
would have people earning less than 400
000 uh pay as much as two-thirds of the
additional tax revenue collected this
year the measure would raise
739 billion of a 10-year span with much
of money coming from a 15 corporate
minimum tax rate okay what are your
thoughts on this would mention well just
goes to show that joe manchin controls
the united states right now okay uh he
shot down uh biden's build back better
deal that two trillion dollar
uh proposed uh bill that went nowhere
and him and chuck schumer behind closed
doors worked this out so
it's basically a skinny down version of
the build back better deal
and
listen whether you like it or not this
is a win for the biden administration
okay
biden's had a pretty good week you know
despite having coped twice in the past
uh two weeks
killed the uh
what's uh osama bin laden's number two
guy
you should get sick and do nothing more
often hey exactly
so um you know i'm a big fan of joe
manchin and uh you know what do they say
killers move in silence and he's he's a
straight killer he's he's the type of
person that we need more of in this
country willing to
work behind closed doors and put your
partisan aside i've always said this and
i'll say it again
any democrat that can consistently get
elected in the reddest state in the
country watch what that man is doing
there's some magic to mansion and uh he
did it again tom
i think this is an old-school bill
in the
you know if you if you read your history
old school congress used to always ask
how are you going to pay for that right
how are you going to pay for that
because the automatic just flopping over
and
impaling
the
the national debt with more debt wasn't
automatic they they took great care in
there and they took great care
about raising the debt ceiling they
weren't so lazy fair about it or were
they debate threatened to shut down the
government for three weeks and then they
raised the debt ceiling anyway this is
an old-school bill and he's to pay for
these things we need these things and i
you know
i think the bill
was kind of balanced because there's a
corporate tax on it and there's also a
change to income tax so he's like
everybody needs to pay for this and i
think that's probably how schumer
that's probably that the tax for
everybody is how manson agreed to it
because schumer's not a tax guy schumer
just wants the program spending that's
in it and he
mansion was like hey we got to adjust it
with taxes so that this thing kind of
pays for itself that's twice so it's
like
that's what i think about it i think
it's your old school build where they're
actually they're actually being
responsible pbd where they're like hey
we got some programs over here and
people are going to pay for it you know
what i like the wealthy they taxed
everybody including corporates you know
what i like about what brett perrault
asked him he said uh well what are you
going to do if they come back and they
do this and they do that and they do
this says well let me tell you what i
told uh president biden
about this bill if you have to keep your
word and i have to keep my word
if they do their part and i do my part
everything's going to be fine but if
they don't i've shown my track record
that i'm not going to vote on certain
things so they have to do their part and
keep their word i thought it was pretty
impressive that he publicly also put it
out there that hey
you play too much politics i'm not
playing the games when it comes down to
these types of policies vinny
while while you read that all that kept
hitting me is because i'm the under 400
000. i'm under the 200 000. i'm gonna it
just keeps going up right it's saying
it's going to go up and then it's going
to go back 2023 they're going to raise
it another 14 billion another 10-year
window it's going to go up another so
everybody that's under 400 000 is going
to be getting taxed over and over and
over and over right that's that's all
i'm saying is that the it's not just the
rich now they're they're going to tax
the [ __ ] out of everybody it's
yes
it's a 16.7 billion american taxpayers
making less than two hundred thousand
dollars in 2023. yeah so
oh go ahead sorry 16.7 billion is money
it is they're being taxed there's no
question about it how much
you know very minimal but you're gonna
be your your taxes went up went up yeah
if number one if it passes we've all
learned that there's a big if but let me
just re this is called the inflation
reduction act of 2022. the big winner
right here is that 15 corporate tax i
know you're not necessarily a big fan of
that i assume
but uh polling states you know i i don't
know the number i think 70 percent of
americans agree with that um inflation
reduction act of 2022 369 billion for
energy security and climate change so
for the greenies out there that's a big
deal for you reduce carbon emissions by
40 by 2030 medicare to negotiate drug
prices i think there's a 90 agreement in
this country that uh drug prices should
go down so that's a big win right there
um
extending obamacare subsidies what have
you uh and then the 15 corporate minimum
tax and then there was one more that i
think is um
let me see if i can find it real quick
um oh the irs funding of the tax police
okay that's how they're gonna basically
essentially a lot of these big
corporations who have been
skirting these loopholes they're the
ones who are going to be paying the
grunt of this if you just want to use
sheer numbers right here
740 billion is going to be from the
corporations
16 billion by american taxpayers here so
the big dogs the amazons of the world
the fang stocks that we talked about the
tech sector
they're the ones paying this bill what
do you think is going to happen when
they raise what is would you say 740
billion by corporations yeah what do you
think those corporations are going to do
they're going to raise their prices
raise their price the taxpayer is paying
for this any way you slice it like any
way you cut it american taxpayers paying
double two ways raising prices and
laying off people yeah that's that's
what happens yeah that's right prices
and lane there are parts of this that i
think are absolutely a win for the byte
administration but 369 billion dollars
to climate change
what would you spend nothing okay
absolutely nothing right now zero zero i
would fix the problems that matter the
economy as it stands right now so you're
basically saying that climate change
doesn't matter right now that's cool no
i don't believe climate change is
america's biggest worry right now i
don't think that
i i mean today
there's i think there's three patients
that just rolled into the emergency room
they got a climate change guy they've
been working on you got a guy just had a
heart attack the heart attacks the
economy you got to fix the heart attack
guy you're not ignoring the climate
change guy but the guy you got to get
after is a guy with a heart attack and
that's the economy i agree it's not it's
not like i i don't think it's binary and
i don't think people are saying it's
binary i'm not saying it's binary but
i'm not a i'm not a climate freak
but i agree that it's good if we change
what we're putting into the water in the
air over time i agree with that but i'm
not a climate freak hey let's talk about
what's going on with fox news and trump
okay so very interesting story that's uh
being talked about by a lot of different
people i don't know how much credibility
there is behind this but
you're seeing some of it fox news owner
uh rupert murdoch is cooling on donald
trump reports say amid wider signs of
discontent this is an insider story
uh murdoch has lost his enthusiasm for
trump the washington post reported
sunday citing several associate of
murdoch
the post said that murdoch's enthusiasm
was ebbing away driven partly by the
congressional hearing on the january 6
riot at the u.s capitol a shift in
murdoch's favor long seen reflected and
approving coverages from outlets like
fox news and the new york post could be
unwelcome should trump choose to run for
president 2024 the post cited its
sources
as signs appeared of a turn against
trump in the wake of january 6 hearing
uh both new york post and wall street
journal published scathing editorial uh
admonishing
trump's behavior spokesman for news corp
the umbrella company for several of
murdock's businesses declined to comment
on the report so do you think this is
real or do you think this is another
propaganda the market is uh creating to
say that his own people are turning
against him adam no i think turning
against okay go ahead sorry i'm sorry go
ahead tom i think turning against him is
a stronger word than what's really
happening
lost their enthusiasm
you know i could see them it's like come
on dude you know let's uh
let's tone it down a little bit i mean i
could see murdoch taking that and that
it is true that those remember editorial
is the opinion of the editor of the
paper that is like the president of the
paper representing it so when they write
an editorial not an article
about january 6 and about other
behaviors that's the paper speaking and
that's the paper's owner speaking so
that interpretation i think is correct
yeah i think well number one
yeah trump got elected because of his uh
masterful use of social media i mean
there's a laundry truck he was a troll
i'm not okay sure that's the personality
side of things no doubt but
he was a master of marketing like trump
don't like trump you know
you have to be willing to acknowledge
the fact that the guy is a master
marketer and what he was able to do on
twitter and social media and facebook
and
ads and all that but now he doesn't have
any of that he's off of twitter
uh correct me if i'm wrong he's still
banned he's still banned oh [ __ ] now
elon musk did not buy twitter you know i
don't want to break the news to anybody
that's still in legal proceedings
uh he's not on youtube you put up
something with trump on youtube that
thing gets taken down we saw what
happened with the elk boys interview
talk he's not on youtube you know he's
not on facebook he doesn't have uh
truth truth social exactly and if you're
in that truth social siphon uh you know
you're gonna believe whatever trump says
anyway yeah and you're a true exactly so
now so we all know where where trump
stands with big tech he's he's off of it
basically but now in terms of legacy
media mainstream media if fox news
owned by the murdoch family
is basically saying i'm just taking this
from his you know what he's going at
face value here if rubach rupert murdoch
is off of the trump bandwagon
that's not very helpful for trump
especially if you want to mix that with
being off of social media and don't
forget
rupert murdoch's sons i think have come
out and have been very outspoken against
trump they are not fans of his
especially if trump has any hopes of
winning the white house i think we all
think he's running again
how's he going to do it without fox by
his side and how is he going to do it
without any of the social media
but being banned on twitter twitter
might help him the fact that he's not
going to be able to say stupid [ __ ] it
might actually help him i'm being
serious he won't be able that's why i
said remember i think the last time i go
if he didn't have thumbs trump would
still be the president because mind you
i still don't think it's him tweeting
tom it's somebody else some like
millennial that's like i'm gonna it's
like a takashi no it's it's him i think
it's definitely a hundred percent
absolutely honestly yeah but i think
that's a really important point vinnie
if trump wasn't on twitter or tweeted
half as much i think he'd still be
president thank you that's 100 bro 100
so this might this this man might
actually help him because it's just
going to be on truth social you want to
hear him go to two soldiers whatever he
wants if he still had twitter he'd still
be president that's okay i agree with
you
and if my aunt had a penis she'd be my
uncle so it is what it is
so here's my question to you without any
of the social media networks allowing
him to come back he's banned from all
the big networks you know big tech
companies and if he doesn't have fox
con can trump still win in 2024 without
those
outlets covering him so so let me give
you what's happened the last seven years
this is my opinion again
uh six years ago
we were all sitting on november third
whatever time it was two o'clock in the
morning you know central standard time
and you're if you're still up you're
like
what the hell tom and i were on the
phone for three hours
do you remember that call totally and we
were looking at the uh there was a new
year's whole time
yeah you told me to new york he's like
patrick this is actually happened i'm
like what are you saying you're saying
when trump beat hillary because nobody
like listen he
people are like what are you talking
about and then you're like yeah and then
when he walked up the look on his face
we're like oh [ __ ] we won
it was such an interesting walk
then the next day he got to work you're
like everybody's sitting there at the
white house hoping this guy's going to
take a month like most people to do to
relax and nah okay let's get to work oh
[ __ ] this actually works man okay that's
a problem we don't like working
presidents we like golfing president we
like guys that are not working this guy
wants to work right off the bat and
romney was coming in for an interview
and all these guys were walking do you
remember that whole thing when it was
all over tv
like oh damn what just happened here and
then
russia story comes out and you're like
oh shoot this guy that's how he won got
it ah yeah exactly he won because he
like yeah russia was a hoax story oh and
hillary clinton 35.
what a freaking derp yeah [ __ ] yeah and
then you're like dude there's no way
biden's winning he goes and he talks 32
people show up there's no way this guy's
winning and you're like on a folding
what in a backyard he's ran a couple
times in the past and the heist he ever
got was one percent and the next thing
elizabeth warren drops out peep drops
out you know bernie drops out everybody
drops it like uh amy drops out
wait
biden's the president he abandons the
president they go what what are we
talking about here so you know well
kovit came from a bad market well we now
know it's not the best so so so many
things have happened
that you in the moment you're like well
here's what's going on and then a year
and a half later like oh
i got it there was just
so listen
we have no clue what's gonna happen here
with trump
uh what i would say is him losing fox
elon and twitter i don't think it helps
the reason for it is the following
reason
as much as we say if he didn't have
twitter he wouldn't
if there wasn't twitter trump's also not
president because what made trump win is
his
ability to troll and everybody was so
interested in what he had to say so the
the
five moments that got him in trouble
were
you know followed by 500 moments that
got him billions of eyeballs that just
wanted to hear him so i do think if he
loses fox i don't think this is good
because uh you know if you lose fox you
can't get on youtube you can't get on
i don't know i don't know how many more
outlets you got and maybe what they're
trying to do is to eliminate him
to position desantis
but uh j just just remember this for
those that are already acting like they
know it all the same camp that was so
certain trump was going to lose
it's part of the same camp that was so
certain he was involved with russia
it's part of the same camp that was so
certain biden was going to lose
it's part of the same camp that
everybody's gotten wrong the last six
years
so he could still end up winning and he
could still end up losing and
you just can't be the person that's kind
of saying well yeah here's what's going
to happen because that's what you hope
it happens correct versus
here's what could happen even i don't
hope that happens so you have to be able
to be logical enough to say
what you want to see happen could be
wrong versus what actually ends up
happening i don't know if i'm making
sense or not but we are living in very
weird times of what happens next well
let's not forget i think adam you've
said this before the what's the best
thing that can happen to cnn trump trump
coming back
money talks ratings talk yeah it's still
early for him oh they'll get they'll
give him all the footage that he needs
you you really think that fox msnbc cnn
are gonna turn down those ratings no way
good point tyler
we'll see if the murdoch uh clan
what do we got we got nine minutes we
got two stories which one you want to do
you want to do navy day putin says
united states main threat you want to do
china shadows lumen you want to do amber
hurt cells or house you want to do
prince charles 1.2 million osama bin
laden do you want to do the person that
won the jackpot what do you want to do
pickle you want to do the uh
saudi arabia story which one do you want
to do pick
beyonce out of everything i didn't say
beyonce he picks he picks me up now
that's another example of someone
apologizing wherever you want to go ppd
tiger woods billionaire tiger woods i
mean i love tiger nothing i thought
tiger was already nothing there there's
nothing there nothing none of those
stories no no i mean tiger woods
billionaire there's nothing there okay
so bad investments he's been sponsors
he's been a lot of things going on
and it's added up and kirk
at least finish it on a high note like
trump sympathy not towards biden like do
we want to finish it with like a uh i
like to know the comedy writer that
wrote that
it was a sympathy note the trump the
story all right let's do the trump uh
trolls uh kobit
stricken biden if you want to pull that
up of saying crazy stuff without twitter
yeah so uh president joe biden's last
positive kobe test again
uh confined him to the white house for
the second time in the last two weeks
earning him the sympathy of many who are
sending the sideline leader get what
wishes including the press
former president who dashes off a doozy
of a sympathy note on sunday joe biden's
second bout of kovitz sometimes referred
to as china virus was sadly misdiagnosed
by his doctors
he instead has dementia but is happily
recovering well joe is thinking of
moving part-time to one of those
beautiful wisconsin nursing homes where
almost 100
residents
miraculously and for the first time in
history had the strength and energy to
vote
even if those votes were cast illegally
get well soon
come on yo where was i
wait where was this posted where was his
club and how that is so freaking how
many issues just those many words
i thought he was banned from twitter
no that's truth this is true
bro how funny again his message will get
out it doesn't matter where your people
will come okay okay pat honestly you
think okay listen it's funny it kind of
sounds like him you think he really
that's per as a comedian that is
freaking hilarious it's misdirection
he's kicking his ass on four different
points and then and then he's still
putting in the illegally vote and he
goes get well soon
that's just brilliant trolling bro like
hate him like how hilarious is that
that's a really good written joke that's
hilarious
[Music]
you know you know what it is it's like
the the breakfast what is the breakfast
thing they do uh when the president gets
up there and they say because like
they're making fun of themselves what is
that thing called you know the
washington correspondent
and he says you know uh earlier uh
hillary uh was walking around and you
know she bumped into me
and uh she said pardon me and i said
i'll think about it
it's good
that's brilliant
and then hillary gets up and she says
look i you know it's always great to
have a uh a person that came out of new
york a strong personality a businessman
a billionaire
uh let's make some noise for uh mayor
bloomberg who's in the house here with
us
oh my god it's the best one to go back
and forth but listen as much as this was
probably written by somebody else it was
inspired by only one person
donald j trump like if if if joe biden
sent a tweet like this you wouldn't even
laugh because you're like first of all
joe you would never in your life yeah
say something like that okay because he
hit that look at all the points so here
he hit kovid being the china virus that
they all you know science was wrong
right then he goes to he does have
dementia but he's hoping he's doing good
and then he goes all those people in the
home that actually voted for the first
time that they got the strength to go
out and vote well that's just come on by
the way great podcast today folks
many of you guys message me and you say
pat i like the interview but i also like
it when you do this format if you like
the format of us just commentating every
once in a while give us a subscribe
and give it a thumbs up to the podcast
today a couple things i do want to share
with you guys for you to be thinking
about number one i'm doing a private
insider webinar today at 4pm for those
that are part of
valuetainment.com insider community if
you are an insider member you and i will
be together today at four o'clock for
those who are not we have a whole social
media community within valuetainment.com
where people talk to each other
entrepreneurs businessman businesswoman
from around the world we have networking
going on right now all over the place on
valuetainment.com if you're not yet an
insider member you can go to
valuetainment.com join the insider
membership i'm doing q a q and a's today
at 4 p.m and outside of that we're
having a vault conference that's coming
up youtube members too for you oh it's
for youtube members valuetainment.com
so youtube insiders get invited to that
as well yep so if you're an insider
member just go to the people
that's great
so valuetainment.com insider as well as
youtube insiders and write it to that as
well phenomenal and then last but not
least
i can't tell you how much i can't wait
to see
many of you at this year's vault
conference i we have so many ridiculous
announcements but more than ever before
there's there's not been a time more
important to than today in my opinion
during these times
for you to recreate yourself and go into
the next phase that we're going into
unknown territories okay 2023 nobody has
any clue what's going to be happening uh
whether it's
the business climate mortgage real
estate finance economy uh of challenges
that's uh foreign we got election that's
coming around the corner these are very
weird times new congress coming new
congress coming
policies are about to change things are
about to change and those who are able
to adapt and are prepared for it will
most likely have the highest odds of
capitalizing during these times i had a
conversation with somebody the other day
and and this person was a a person from
the insurance industry and they said
look we're bringing our entire crew
they're bringing like 25 of their guys
that are coming to this event but guys
are bringing their entire sales force
one of the guys i talked to he says man
i i can't make it this year i'm probably
going to come next year and i said you
know to be honest with you i don't think
you're ever coming for three years
you've been saying this and i think the
problem isn't that you're coming next
year the problem is
you have a tendency of saying to
everybody you're eventually going to do
it next year your problem is a
procrastination problem i never want to
go into a new year
without certain things that are the
unknown let me explain i'm currently we
just
signed a uh deal with uh my uh next
business book being published i'm very
excited about it we'll be announcing
this here soon published with uh a
massive publisher we'll be announcing
the details of this book here soon and
i'm getting my fiction book that's being
published and that's going to be coming
out in 2024 the business books coming
out q4 of 2023 okay
and then outside of that we got a couple
companies that we're investing in
vitamin investment group is doing big
things we got some announcements that
we'll be making to you
and then there are certain
i mean i i wish i could say you know
four of these things there's a lot of
surprises but the moral the story is the
following i never ever ever want to go
into a new year without any new unknowns
and the only way you have unknowns is by
you recreating yourself so if you
haven't yet registered to go to the
vault i would love to spend two and a
half days with you by uh being with the
folks that we're having robert kiyosaki
is going to be there uh my good friend
kevin connolly will be there from the
entourage he'll be there uh we're going
to have a chas paul and terry from bronx
tale doing his 90 minutes script he's
going to play every role from the this
is a broadway show that you're going to
see performance wow good friend
frederick the silva top illusionist uh
will be there as well and i think we
have also
uh uh anyways couple other people will
also be yeah andy fast exactly who was
the cfo they did a documentary on that
one african academy cfo of enron
enron that caused a hundred thousand
employee company to go out of business
and he's got a completely different
version of the story i think he went to
jail for eight years even his wife i
think went for a minute he's gonna be
sharing what happened during that time
you may want to hear that side of the
story so you don't kind of go through it
yourself now if you haven't yet
registered for the vault uh the website
is
the vaultconference.com once again
thevaultconference.com
it'll be in miami at the diplomat from
august 31st to september 3rd and our
entire crew will also be here adam will
be there vinnie will be there tom will
be there mario everybody will be there
we'll see you guys tomorrow having said
that what pack i say one thing yes sir i
have sorry to cut you off i have a one
my podcast funny how launches today at 1
p.m
and i'm gonna look at the camera one
guys this is
brilliant people money
mine is just gonna be comedy and
outlandish stuff i'm just warning
everybody
it's gonna be it's purely comedy you
were offended by the word [ __ ] i
suggest you not go watch it exactly
valuetainment comedy at 1pm yeah okay
all right gang have a great day and i
think we're doing this again today's
what today thursday thursday with zuma
oh we're doing thursday with zoobee
soupy's gonna be on thursday we'll see
you guys on thursday take everybody bye
bye bye
you